francis do you enjoy social media of
course i love spending my days being
called a fat bigot by strangers
and do you think that woke buyers on
social media is getting ridiculous
yeah what happened to pilot was a
travesty for freedom of speech online
what if i told you there was a brand new
social media platform that encouraged
free speech
that's brilliant will it be able to show
off my sick abs on it as well
hopefully not the new platform is called
retalk and it is
absolutely exploding right now they have
discussion forums around any topic
from gardening to ancient history all
the way to current politics
that sounds great but a lot of these
free speech platforms
just attract all the worst people from
both sides
or as we call them here trigonometry
fans correct
joking aside what makes retalk different
is it's moderated to keep away
extremists but instead of being uber
work
they take a balanced view to moderation
wow how do they find so many moderators
who don't have pink hair i don't know
maybe they hire people from
all over the political spectrum great
joke mate
no big tech company would ever do that
retalk
insists on civility and they're
particularly keen to foster
conversations for people in the center
and on the center
right you can even go on there and
discuss trigonometry and your favorite
episodes
so all i need to do to access this great
site is click on the link and it will
take me straight there
yep and if you're a listener go to
retalk.com
that's r e t a l k dot com
and start having intelligent
conversations you know they'll be
intelligent conversations because
francis hasn't worked out how to join
yet
i haven't i was lucky enough to have my
father as a father and when i was
diagnosed with arthritis
and i was diagnosed when i was seven so
i was in grade two
and i was really sick
i didn't wanna go to school i was really
tired i was limping
like um in grade three i had a hard time
walking
and he told me never use your illness as
an excuse
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantin kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our fantastic
guest today is a podcast host michaela
peterson welcome to trigonometry
thank you thank you so much for having
me uh it's so
good to have you we were just as we were
setting up the interview with talking
about how excited we are to talk to you
because francis and i both did a little
bit of research as we we
sometimes do on you and your life story
is is just you've had so many
difficulties that you've had to deal
with in your life we just first of all
wanted to talk to you about
that and because you know you go from
having a lot of health issues as a kid
and mental health issues then your dad
becomes a superstar like there's a whole
then he's a
nazi then there's this whole thing right
all sorts of things in the last year
you've had to look after him
there's been a ton of stuff going on and
it's incredible how
well put together you are in spite of
all these difficulties so we were just
you know we talk about ideas on
trigonometry more than anything but
i think mindset is a big thing that we
also want to talk about and
you know you are an example of a lot of
resilience uh
how has your life been and just talk to
us about all of that
how well put together i appear yeah
talk to us about how well put together
you appear go for it
so to give people a brief background
about the health issues i went through
and just
kind of what's happened i'm 29 now when
i was seven i was diagnosed with
juvenile rheumatoid arthritis and it was
everywhere
except for my spine uh so i had
at that point i had 32 joints affected
when i was 12 i was diagnosed with
bipolar type 2
mainly really severe depression uh when
i was 21 i was diagnosed with idiopathic
hypersomnia which is basically
narcolepsy it's just like
we're not sure why but you're sleeping
all the time
uh i had rashes and i was getting sicker
and sicker
when i was 17 i had my hip and ankle
replaced from the
arthritis that wasn't kept under control
with the immune suppressants i was
injecting myself with
since i was eight so i didn't
like as a kid i guess if you're sick
it's very
because you don't know a lot of other
kids it's hard to tell
what the difference between your life
and somebody else's is i had my brother
to compare myself to and i was like oh
why me
like why is that me and not him because
he's like perfect example of health he's
like how's that fair
um and then when i was 23 and i kept
getting sicker and sicker and i was on
more and more medication
and my skin stopped healing uh
i thought okay i'm i have to figure this
out or
it's gonna kill me and we have i have
second cousins and a lot of autoimmune
problems on my
dad's side and some of those people were
really sick i had a second cousin who
passed away when she was 30 from
a skin autoimmune disorder that or
something they're not entirely sure
but she had symptoms that were similar
to mine but her she didn't have
arthritis
so i thought okay i have to figure this
out so i i never really thought about
myself as resilient because i thought
what other option do i have
um i'm just gonna you know you either
learn
and survive or you're going to die
that's
kind of how i thought about it i'm also
kind of prone to volatility and
anger which is i think part of actually
what helped me get through
the sicknesses instead of welting away i
got angry
um so if we want to talk about
resiliency a little bit i guess
and mindset and how to get through that
was just the health aspect right
right okay i'll rewind a little bit so i
got i started to get healthy because i
went on this like insane diet adventure
and
i kind of got raked over the coals in
the media for that
um i went super super low carb which is
more at least you hear about it now and
that helped a lot of my autoimmune
symptoms and then i ended up on
an all-meat diet not because i wanted to
be controversial or only eat meat
because it's actually not fun
but because the alternative was having
an autoimmune disorder and a mood
disorder
and then at the same time my dad went on
the diet he lost a bunch of weight
because he had autoimmune problems and
and really severe depression he started
feeling better and at the same time
he got famous and there was all that
controversy which was incredibly
stressful
uh i think even just a positive
experience with
fame is incredibly stressful but
like my dad's experience was a lot of it
was negative
we figured out that a lot of the media
sources were lying
about him right and you can't really
tell what they're lying about but
when a story comes out about your dad
about things he said
that he didn't say it's pretty then you
go well what what else are they lying
about like is everything i read from
them
about other people a lie so i dealt with
that
um i had a baby pretty
like some of these some of these things
it seems i kind of brought onto myself i
had a baby
when i was 24 um
in a fairly new relationship and that's
my husband but
it was like incredibly stressful at the
time uh
and then in the last couple of years my
family's gotten incredibly sick so it
was like as soon as i got healthy
in this insane way that nobody believed
that the media made fun of
um my mom got this deadly
kidney cancer collecting gut cancer
and she almost died but she made it
which wasn't supposed to happen but it
did
and then my dad had
had an issue you could say with
um anti-anxiety medication so it turns
out if you
suddenly kind of stop taking ssris
people don't know about this
but if you suddenly stop taking ssris
you can get ssri withdrawal
and you're not really told that there's
ssri withdrawal
when you go on ssris people know about
opiate withdrawal
they know about benzodiazepine
withdrawal
um but they don't really know there's
ssri withdrawal
so part of the neurological problems dad
and i both had
that drove us towards this low-carb diet
were from ssri withdrawal
which he ended up treating with
benzodiazepines
turns out that's not a good idea um and
he ended up with
a side effect called akathesia and
akathesia
is the worst thing i've ever seen and
i've seen some pretty gnarly things
having a hip and ankle replacement isn't
isn't
great um but academic is a movement
disorder
and it's a side effect of some psych
meds that people don't really know about
so then we dealt with that for two years
and it looks as if things are kind of on
the upswing now
so like mom had her near-death thing
dad had his i had mine for a really long
time
uh although it was kind of slow and
drawn out and
i wouldn't say it was as dramatic as mom
and dad's but we're hoping that there's
a bit of a pause
um but i think i got through it by using
anger
so instead of being like this is going
to flatten me
it was really you know whenever i got
that feeling like oh i can't i can't
handle this like how is this happening
this is too much
you know i'm in too much pain this is
too hard i can't
handle this when whenever i had that i
can't handle this
pop into my head then i'd have this
surge of anger where it was like no
[ __ ] you this is not what takes me out
like
i don't know who i was swearing at but
reality was just like this is not the
direction my reality is going to
continue in
and then i'd kind of wrangle it back
under control and try and push it in a
different direction
um and i i'm writing a
i'm writing a memoir at the tender age
of 29
uh just about going through the
autoimmune disorder and what happened
with my dad
and my mom and it was just a bunch of
random things that happened to me and i
realized
last week that the kind of underlying
theme was maybe
resiliency and how to stay
like alive if you get hit over and over
and over again
and i think especially nowadays even
just
experiencing lockdowns that people are
it's really hard um and you can be you
know you can
you can be in a pretty good place and in
a lockdown and your your life can still
kind of suck
but if you're in a bad place and then
you put a lockdown on top of that
like people need to
find how to become resilient i guess
within them
nowadays or they're not going to make it
um so and michaela you you said you use
the word resiliency but what does that
mean to you because
a number of times we use these words and
they mean different things to different
people
um to me it means if you get hit it
makes you stronger
so it's not just limping around
it's if you get a hurt you can turn that
into something that makes you stronger
you know one of the things i've been
thinking about is if if nothing bad
ever happened in your life again you
would still be like i've had my fair
share of challenges right
like that's how i feel just knowing some
of the things you've been dealing with
uh and i it struck me that's kind of
like a big theme in your dad's work as
well this
idea that life is unfair and you have to
learn to deal with it
like how do you deal with the fact that
life is unfair
you have to you have to try and find the
positives in situations
and you'll get people who say
oh god you'll get people who say you
know you go to a funeral and then
you come out and you're miserable and
someone will go well they're in a better
place now and you just like
you just want to slap them so i don't
mean like
find find i mean find good things
in like terrible situations i don't mean
that the terrible situation is worth it
i just mean you're gonna have a terrible
situation happen to you
like everybody is everybody experiences
death
from someone they love so that at least
is probably going to happen and then
there might be more there might be
disease which is horrible
um or there might just be you know
lockdowns which
which isn't disease and death but
it's it's not good and so you have to
try
and find the good in it so for me
uh having having it's easier
it's i find it's easier if it's
happening to you
and not to someone you love because
that's really hard to wrap your mind
around but if it's happening to you
then you can say well assuming this
situation whatever i'm in is going to
end um maybe i can stop this from
happening to other people
so part of the reason i've been so vocal
about the diet that worked for me is
because i've seen it work for other
people
so if i can stop you know one other
person
from having to live their life in
chronic pain
then me having the chronic pain is more
worth it
and the more people i can help makes it
more worth it and at the moment
i think that i've helped enough people
that i wouldn't
take it back so i think the way you
survive
really terrible situations is you find
the good in whatever happened and you
make
whatever happened to you worth it and
that's really tricky when it's like
somebody you love dying like
that's on another level but i don't see
any other way
that you can psychologically survive
and it's a really really good point i
mean it becomes even more tricky when
you factor in depression when your own
mind
is ill i mean what can you i mean that
is surely the ultimate isn't it trying
to overcome something when your own mind
is
conspiring against you yeah so i i have
a few comments on that too
i had so i i had um bipolar type 2 but
my main symptom was this severe
depression and
when people asked what that was like it
was like
like it was like a really heavy version
of when you're in a bad area and you're
walking down an alley and you think
you're gonna get jumped but you had that
feeling
all the time so it's like constant
jumpiness and that's but it's way worse
than that
um it was like walking through tar
all the time like everything was heavy
to lift up except it's worse
um i i i always at the time when i was
depressed i used to be like you know
it's kind of like your dog died
and you can go to a party but your dog
just died so you always have that
feeling
and then my dog died and i was like oh
that was not nearly as bad as this
depression
so um how do you
i think that you have to figure out how
to tackle the depression
because when i was depressed i couldn't
trust anything i was thinking
it was always you know i'd have this
wonderful opportunity present itself and
now
i have a much easier time judging
opportunity for what it's worth but i'd
have this opportunity to present itself
and then i'd think well these are all
the 10 000 ways it can go wrong
and then inevitably it would and i'd be
like well why does that happen to my
brother like he just assumes
everything's gonna be okay and it is
and i assume everything's gonna be wrong
and it always is wrong so i wouldn't i
why wouldn't i continue assuming it's
gonna go wrong um
but i think like this is why i'm a big
proponent of diet to be honest i think
that if you have a psych condition and
you're walking around
in pain you need to get the source of
the condition under control and
generally speaking unless it's
situational
i think that a lot of that can be
handled by less inflammatory diets so
less carbs
and people underestimate how much of a
difference that can make because
you go oh well you know don't eat as
much sugar and it's like my depression
is way worse than me
eating sugar but um if you go low carb
i've seen that help a lot of people
if you're situationally depressed
because someone near you is sick or
dying then
you have to just truck through that
until it's over and you have to remember
that
these periods of time are awful when
they're happening but they will
end just have to keep that in mind like
this isn't forever
especially like people have that with
this lockdown right
like there's this number of suicides is
devastating
people who are already kind of at risk
and then they're just like i'm isolated
i can't handle this
but people have to remember that this
isn't forever there's like
there's gonna be a way out so just just
wait it out
and a lot of getting through tough
things is waiting
unfortunately that's really good point i
mean we talked to some of our fans every
month
and uh the one we did just a couple of
days ago it was
yeah people are really struggling with
these lockdowns and i think as you say
that sense of
knowing that this two shall pass
can be very helpful for very bad times
like now but also actually for very good
times sometimes you're too high
uh on the immediate success and you also
want to
take a more measured approach to i guess
with what i'm saying one of the things
i'm hearing michelle in a lot of what
you're saying
you're talking about anger and you're
talking about finding solutions
right and that takes us very neatly into
something we talk about
on the show a lot which is the culture
war how do you
as someone has been through all of that
and has found that the best solution for
your issues was to
to get into action to do something
how do you feel about what i would
describe as people being taught to be
victims being taught to have the exact
opposite approach
to make their problems someone else's
fault that
that they just can be sad about instead
of actually taking action what do you
what do you make of all of that
yeah i think it i think that could be
deadly like i think that that ruins
lives
like i was lucky enough to have my
father as a father
and when i was diagnosed with arthritis
and i was diagnosed when i was seven
so i was in grade two and i was
really sick i didn't want to go to
school i was really tired i was limping
like um in grade three i had a hard time
walking
and he told me never use your illness as
an excuse
and i had all the excuses because
i had arthritis everywhere and i was
pretty
miserable and in pain um but he said
like
err on the side of not using it as an
excuse
and i think i probably i think erring on
the side of not using it as an excuse at
all
is safer even though that's not exactly
fair
right there were times when i probably
could have stayed in bed
um but it doesn't help people and
people are taught right now something
unfair happens to them and it is unfair
and unfair things happen to everybody
and some people they hit a lot
worse especially people who are sick
right
um but telling them
telling them so there's there's a number
of problems
one telling them that it's someone
else's fault means they can't do
anything about it so it takes
it takes all the power away from them
one of the issues i had with
i've got issues with a lot of things but
i have issues with the medical system
and
how they treat chronically ill people
because they say
this is a disease and you're going to
have it forever and it takes
takes any hope of getting better away
because they say that's not possible so
you don't even look
people don't even look they go this is
you know this is just what it is i have
to live with it
and i think even in that respect it
would be more helpful if you were kind
of
told oh yeah you're really sick and we
can't help you
so you're gonna have to figure it out
and if and if people
were told that for these other things
that they say are unfair like
if you're not born a white person if
you're female if you're transgender
whatever
it would probably be better to say you
know you might have a harder time in
some aspects but you're going to have to
figure out what to do about it
not this is the patriarchy's fault
and you're screwed like when i i took
sciences in university
and this was before things got really
weird in universities
but every two months i'd have somebody
and it wasn't a science student it was
somebody from
some student group come in and they'd go
you know
we know all the women in this class
worked really hard to get here
and it was just like that is so
condescending
like like taking away yeah i studied
hard
as did everybody else but being like i
know it was extra hard for you
and just like screw off with
with your fake i don't even know what
that is fake empathy
but i'm i'm i think the victim mentality
that
people are being told is the right way
to live life is
really dangerous and i think it'll end
up making people like harming people
because they won't be able to escape it
they'll just be stuck in this victim
box forever do you have a website or do
you plan to have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be council culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
how do you think we're being told that
why do you think we're being encouraged
to believe that narrative
i don't have any like great conspiracy
theories or
or anything i don't know if it's coming
from the top i think it's just easier
like if you get sick lying around in bed
it
is easier than continuing to
go about life pretending nothing's wrong
um so i i think it's an easy sell
and it's easy for groups of people to
feel sorry about themselves together
um i don't know what do you do what do
you guys think
do you think there's a reason we're
being sold this yeah i think you've hit
the nail on the head i think also
uh people crave a tribe don't they we
all want to be part of
a group yeah and if you put all those
things together and here's a tribe
we can all be victims together we can
all be oppressed together we can make
that
the thing that we talk about the thing
that we quote unquote resist or whatever
it is
i think people really want that that
belonging don't they
and i also think people like simple
solutions to complex problems yeah
yeah see that's where i'd go i'd say
it's just it's easier it's easier
whining about your situation than trying
to figure it out
it's really hard trying to figure out a
problem it's a lot easier being like
this is completely
i'm not able to do this because it's
somebody else's fault and
look at all the people around me who
agree with me yeah so i
i guess the tribe is a big part of it
too and for something like
like i originally saw this because i was
sick there was a lot of catering to
being sick
and you see that too with the say the
fat acceptance movement
i can see where i can see where it came
from
but accepting being sick
is really not good you shouldn't make
the norm
um or or everybody will be sick and
they'll be no reason for them to get
better if they're just like this is
normal
it's dangerous but we also glorify being
sick now don't we if you see you know
you see it with
in people's bios you know you know bpd
depressive it's become an identity badge
yeah yeah it's weird because okay so
i remember in maybe like 2004 or
something around then there was this big
push
for um anxiety and depression mainly and
they're saying you know these are real
things people are suffering from
it's not just situational like this is a
disease
and i think that was important because
it is a disease and it's not just people
being
feeling sorry for themselves right
there's there's different types of
depression but the inflammatory
depression that's a serious
disease and then it just went
sideways like um i can understand again
with the fat acceptance movement
a lot of these people who have have
tried to lose weight
a whole bunch of different ways and
they're exercising like i've known
people who are you know
350 pounds and run all the time and
they're still 350 pounds
and so they go well i've tried
exercising
it's not working it's genetic and it's
not my fault
so why are people bullying me about it
and that's kind of where the fat
acceptance movement came
out of and so i think it's partly it's
just
people aren't educated on being healthy
and i think the same thing happened with
you know i have bipolar and now it's in
my bio
is they honestly don't know what to do
about it and so they're saying well
that's who i am don't bug me about it
because i can't change it
um that's my opinion i think i think
part of the problem is
people don't know how to deal with it
and that goes back to the issues i have
with the medical system
telling you that there's nothing you can
do about it you have it for life here's
some medication
yeah because it does seem that very much
that you know people
are you know medication a lot of them
like relatives who are very very close
to me just
are medicated for the entire for their
entire lives and but you really believe
that with
diet that you can overcome it so could
you just go into that a little bit
yeah i'll go into it in like brief
detail so i
i was brought into like if you have a
sick kid
generally speaking and you're a good
parent you try absolutely everything
under the sun to get them better so i
was brought to every holistic
practitioner that my mom could find my
dad was like that's
that's [ __ ] but my mom was like no
we'll try everything
like muscle testing like everything
and so i grew up and what i saw was my
mom spending
hoards of money and we didn't have any
money at that time like
we weren't buying magazines or anything
because we had we had
like not enough money my mom was to stay
at home
mom and so i thought these are like
quacks taking advantage of
sick people and charging the money
because they're desperate and this is
so wrong and it made me really angry and
that
drove me away from the more natural
route plus the medical system was saying
this is uncontrollable um and we're the
scientists here those other people
aren't scientists
but then when i started doing research
and i actually looked at the science
because it turns out when a paper is
written
it takes approximately 30 years to get
implemented into hospitals
so if the people in the hospitals are
saying they're scientists they're also
not
not right they're scientists 30 years
ago
so i started looking into it and it
turns out leaky gut
um is a is an actual thing and that's
because of the diets people have
nowadays which are highly processed
high sugar uh it does cause a level of
gut damage and when you get gut damage
foods you're eating can escape into your
blood
and then that can provoke an immune
response because your body's like what
the hell
is you know a large protein of grain
doing in here and in certain susceptible
people this can provoke an entire immune
response
so they've found out that with people
with arthritis
there are proteins called lectins which
are in grains they're in legumes
they're in a lot of plants and your body
sees one of these lectins that escapes
into your blood
and then provokes an immune response
which is a totally reasonable response
um but lectins also look like joint
tissue
so it can miscommunicate and then direct
an immune response towards joint tissue
so this leaky gut theory that natural
past had been talking about for
20 years there is scientific evidence
behind it
and if you have food proteins escape
into your body it can
just generally cause inflammation and
there's been a huge link between
inflammation and depression
like one of the most closely associated
symptoms
like physical symptoms with depression
is low back pain
so it's not just in your head it's it's
also physical
and i've seen thousands and thousands of
people get better
simply going low carb and the reason
that seems to work is because
there are certain foods that cause leaky
gut more than others
and this is probably combined with
antibiotic use medication
like our bodies aren't we're not like we
can't drink
paint right we can't we can't eat
absolutely everything and not
get sick and you can see that really
well by some of the middle states
if you're just there people are like
visibly ill compared to
places in europe and um
it looks like there's good evidence that
a lot of that has to do with diet which
is actually good news because you can
change your diet
so it's a more hopeful story than
sorry you're just genetically
predisposed to being 400 pounds
like come on is that is that really an
easier sell
than maybe it has to do with what you
eat
and it it's very interesting because
again with corona it
you know there were people were told
about vitamin d and we were you know
we were we had the government telling us
about different things but no one ever
explained why diet can help keep you
healthy
and help prevent you from getting
certain illnesses especially corona
so if somebody is in that place where
they are depressed what are things that
people can do
in order to overcome it for example with
diet
okay so the simplest thing if you really
don't want to change your diet
which is fair because most people don't
i would
minimum stop eating gluten-containing
grains
and i got told when i was sick too by
naturopaths to stop eating gluten
and i had brushed it off as kind of a
california girl fad
uh and that turned out when i started
delving into the science and looking at
leaky gut that turned out to be
completely wrong
so lots of people can feel better simply
by removing gluten-containing grains
so that's basically all the yummy foods
it's like wheat rye barley so that gets
rid of
beer pasta pizza cake
doughnuts like any type of cakey dessert
um it's in soy sauce so you have to like
really
it's in twizzlers gluten is in a lot of
places but
that you've lost francis already okay
i'll embrace the depression michaela
[Laughter]
that that can help and generally if you
do it for six weeks
this is what i tell people to do so go
gluten-free for six weeks
it's pretty easy nowadays because they
make gluten-free foods they're not as
good but they're there
um and then at the end of six weeks like
have a couple of slices of pizza and
just see how you feel
over the next couple days so that's a
pretty simple test
now that's pretty good for people who
aren't like half dead
if you're in the same boat as me then
i tell the or you have an autoimmune
disorder um
or a really severe psychiatric condition
i tell those people to go like way
low carb get rid of grains dairy soy
um and if you can manage to get rid of
those three things like as long as you
can convince yourself it has something
to do with diet then you can kind of
figure it out
it's the initial hump of being like does
diet actually have anything to do with
my health um that i had a problem with
as soon as i
limited it reintroduced and had this
huge inflammatory reaction i was like oh
okay well i'll look into this um so
minimum i'd say get rid of gluten and if
you want to go a little bit more then
get rid of grains entirely and dairy
and that that could help immensely a lot
of people who are super super overweight
if they just stop eating grains they
lose pounds
without calorie restricting same with
mood but it depends your level
on your level of severity like when i
cut gluten
it probably made 10 percent of a
difference it was noticeable but it
wasn't enough
for me to be like diet's the cure
it's an interesting point you make i
mean i think at this stage of
like scientific knowledge to suggest
that diet has nothing to do with your
health or
or mood is is absurd i think it's
you know it's obvious you just have to
look at your own life and look at what
you eat and how you feel afterwards it's
um why do you think we're so attached to
this idea that diet
is it just because we like eating the
bad food and would rather than would not
cut it out
i think so i would guess so i mean this
is where i get a little bit
conspiratorial
because there is evidence like um
there is evidence of large
food companies kind of infiltrating the
government or lobbying
like a lot of grains and soy and corn
are subsidized by the government
um there have been scientific studies
that aren't published because
there isn't enough there's no nobody's
funding like these
no one's funding those but you can get
like soy companies funding the ones
saying soy is a health food
so that's where i get a little
conspiratorial but i think probably the
simplest
answer is people just like how
does certain types of food taste um
and you know i find that the foods that
taste
the best other than steak but the foods
that taste
the best probably are the ones that
aren't as good for you
like when i started cutting things out
it was my favorite foods that were
making me sick
i used to drink like i used to drink a
hot glass of milk when i was a kid
before i went to bed at night
and dairy was hugely inflammatory for my
arthritis i had sugar and cinnamon on
toast which is clearly not a health food
but it's
absolutely wonderful and um i had bread
at every meal and
that was one of the biggest ones so like
cheese and bread and i put soy sauce on
everything
and it was cheese and bread and soy that
were the ones that were the most
inflammatory and they were the ones that
made me go like
mmm when i eat them um so how sad was it
to say goodbye to them
i i'm telling you if i would be in tears
i cried okay so when i i'm not even
kidding i i cut everything out and i was
like i don't know if this will really
make a difference but
if i'm doing kind of a a rigorous study
of why i'm so sick i have to rule out
diet
at least so i did a month-long um
kind of test where i went really low
carbs so that's like
meat and greens and certain like sweet
potatoes and parsnips it was really low
carb
and i felt a lot better within the first
month
abnormally better and then i
reintroduced
first i reintroduced sour patch kids
because i was like they don't have any
gluten and soy and dairy
um and that didn't go particularly well
and then i reintroduced cheese because
it was one of the things i missed
and i had such a horrible reaction to
cheese that yeah i cried the night i
cried afterwards when i was like i can't
it makes me too sick and i cried um
so it's really hard and people get
really intense cravings when they stop
certain foods so it's no wonder
plus people get pissy when you're like
hey that
disease you have is perhaps treatable
and a lot of people when they're talking
about diet
presented in a way as if the person
they're talking to has done something
wrong
like that's how it was always presented
to me well why don't you eat healthier
and i was like what the hell you think
might like whether or not i eat healthy
has to do with me
having my joints replaced you [ __ ]
plus i was eating like
rice and chicken and broccoli
and milk like i wasn't eating terribly
um and so it depends how it's presented
you can't be like
eat healthier you're just you know lazy
that's why you're sick
that's not going to go over well yeah
yeah well you're losing francis rapidly
he can just see himself crying
at the point of cutting out anything to
do with carbs it goes away
with chips more or fries as you would
say yeah
sweet potatoes fries would be better but
but the cravings
you have to be suffering pretty hard to
start dropping foods
or you have to be one of those freaks
that exercises all the time
and just chooses to do it but i don't
identify with those people
no i i've met some of them and i've
avoided them on principle ever since
i was going to ask you do you get a lot
of [ __ ] from vegans michaela
you know what not really compared to
like there are some other
carnivore doctors and what they do is
preach this carnivore diet
and um they get harassed all the time i
think or at least they talk about
getting harassed all the time but
i don't really get bugged but mostly i
think it's because i'm saying
like i was really sick and now i'm not
and they're kind of like
okay that looks like it was true
so maybe it worked for her um but i also
get a lot of i just get a lot of hate
across the board so i also kind of igno
i might ignore some of it
it doesn't seem vegan gains has been an
issue
he's a he's a he's a disaster of a human
but other than that not really you said
you get a lot of hate all around
what what have you done to get hate why
do you get hate
um well i can it started with
this meat diet and so i can understand
where that came from because it was like
oh
girl goes around saying meat diet cured
her disorders and that
it can help other people and that
probably would have made me angry too
before i gotten healthier so i can kind
of understand where that's coming from
plus that's way easier to get mad at
that than to be like yeah that's
reasonable
especially if you don't understand it at
all and then after that
well when my dad got really sick and we
had to bring him to russia
i can understand why that made people
mad because people were like why the
hell
did you go to russia and they don't know
the backstory and why we ended up doing
it
so it's easier being angry and then i
think that there are also just people
who live in the basement for most of
their lives and have nothing
better to do than insult people who are
perhaps doing more with their life than
they are and i think that's probably
where the majority of my hate comes from
i just think there are better targets
for those people surely like
um i i find it very strange that people
would come after you but it's equally
it's something that that is
i think he was asked recently whether he
would have a run for office and he said
that he wouldn't because
of the amount of cruel behavior that you
receive as a public figure
and we do live in the strange world
don't we where the moment anyone sticks
their head above the parapet
whether it's him or you with with the
dire or anything
suddenly you just become just so many of
our guests
like we get them on the show and then i
look at our twitter afterwards
when they've retweeted it and they just
have people whose
only thing seemingly is they follow one
person around the internet
and post crap on anything that that
person shares
i said how how i don't get it like do
you not have anything better to do
no they don't and they're very sad
people
like those people are i can't imagine
that's a happy person
um not that that makes it okay like it
you can get
you can have terrible things happen to
you and you become this like
evil human being that just you know why
was i put through so much misery why am
i in so much pain let me inflict pain on
everybody around me
right you get those people that go
through horrible circumstances and end
up like that
or you get people who go through
horrible circumstances and then they try
and help other people
to avoid the same kind of suffering and
so the people
just like following people around on
twitter or the people who've probably
been through some [ __ ]
and just feel like it would be better if
they doled it out instead of trying to
limit the amount of suffering in the
world